[موسيقى]
دور الاله لم يعد قاصرا على مساعده
الانسان على انجاز اعماله في وقت وجيز فقد
بات بوسعها تعلم كيفيه اكمال المهام دون
تعليمات بشريه صالحه الفضل يرجع الى تطور
الهائل في تقنيات وبرمجيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي واستخدامها في قطاعات عديده
كالامن والبيئه والبحث والتعليم والصحه
والثقافه والتجاره وغيرها وقد حضر باحثون
وقاده في قطاع التكنولوجيا من مخاطر
الجسيم على المجتمع والانسانيه لانظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي دعينا الى وقف تطويرها
لمده سته اشهر الى حين اعتماد انظمه حمايه
منها ترافق هذا مع توقعات بان يحل الذكاء
الاصطناعي مستقبلا محل قرابه 300 مليون
وظيفه في قصتنا ثوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
نعرض لبعض نماذج استخدام تطبيقاته العديده
كما في روبوتات توصيل الطلبات وخدمات
الدردشه الاليه
فحسب فقد بات بامكان الذكاء الاصطناعي
كتابه المقالات ونظم الشعر ورسم لوحات
فنيه يصعب تمييزها عن الابداع البشري
نناقش مع خبراء ومعنيين الهواجس المحيطه
باستخدام تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتاثيرها على القوى العامله البشريه وما
يمثله استخدام بعضها من تهديد لقيم
الخصوصيه
والاستقلاليه الفرديه اما بقيه هذه القصه
فنستكملها مع الدكتور احمد خليفه المقرمد
المدير التنفيذي المؤسس لمعهد قطر لبحوث
الحوسبه بجامعه حمد بن خليفه وعضو مؤسسه
قطر والدكتور دانيال ارايا خبير الذكاء
الاصطناعي والحوكمه والشريك الرئيسي في
القمه القانونيه العالميه والزميل الاول
بمركز الابتكار في الحوكمه الدوليه لبحوث
الذكاء الاصطناعي والانظمه المستقله نسال
ضيفينا الكريمين عن الافاق المستقبليه
لتقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي والتحديات التي
تواجهها وكيف يمكن حمايه البشر من تغولها
وامكانيه التحكم فيه وتطويعه بما يحقق
النتائج المفيده لكن ما رايكم بدايه ان
نشاهد القصه ونبدا بعدها الحوار
رقبه تلو الاخرى وعبر التاريخ تنظر
التكنولوجيا قدما سواء كانت المجتمعات
جاهزه لذلك ام لا في بعض الاحيان يكون من
الافضل الاحتفاظ بالقوه العامله البشريه
لحمايه مصادر دخل الناس
بتموت في وظائف جديده تستحدث
تفوقك ونحن اذا بدنا نحن نبقى كمان على
السوق لازم نحن نعرف نستخدمه الذكاء
والسرعه والدقه والجوده اربع صفات
اقتنص بعاد من الانسان اعطتها للاله في
حقبه اصبحت الاله فيها في كثير من الاحيان
الفاعل للمفعول به تزحف بذكاء نحو فرص
العمل فتستولي عليها فتثير المخاوف لدى
اصحابها وكل ذلك لم يكن في الحسبان عندما
عرف العالم الثوره الصناعيه الاولى في
منتصف القرن الثامن عشر
في جامعه بالمملكه المتحده
الباحثه بمركز ليفر هيوم المختص بدراسه
مستقبل الذكاء الاصطناعي مع الثوره
الصناعيه الاولى كانت تحول من العماله
اليدويه الى استخدام الالات في التصنيع تم
اختراع محرك البخار ما احدث نقله كبيره
انعكست على التوسع في انشاء المصانع على
سبيل المثال ثم جاءت الثوره الصناعيه
الثانيه والتي تميزت بانشاء السكك
الحديديه واختراع التيليجراف واكتشاف
الكهرباء وهي الابتكارات التي تضافرت معا
مانحه الصناعه نطاقا واسعا للنمو والتطور
الكبيرين مع ثوره الصناعيه الثالثه والتي
تعرف ايضا بالثوره الرقميه بدا عصر
الكمبيوتر والاتمه حيث استخدمت التقنيات
الرقميه على نطاق كبير وهي تقنيات التي
اظهرت قدرتها على الاستيلاء على قدر من
قوه عقولنا بالاضافه الى مهاراتنا اليدويه
لذا فانما يجعل الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه
مختلفه بحق وقدرتها على دمج كل هذا معا
حيث اتمته العمل اليدوي وقوه الدماغ
والذكاء الاصطناعي وربط الانظمه
الفيزيائيه والبيولوجيه والبرمجيات تحت
سقف واحد
بمعهد بروكنز المختص في المساعده على سد
الفجوه بين المعرفه والسياسات العامه
الاصطناعي هو تقنيه تعتمد على عمل
الحواسيب والتي تتطور بسرعه كبيره انه يحل
المشكلات عن طريق استخدام السرعه الهائله
لاجهزه الكمبيوتر للتعرف على الانماط
المختلفه للسلوك وتحديد المشكلات والتنبؤ
بردود الافعال والتعرف على سلسله من
البيانات التي تتكرر بطريقه يمكن التعرف
عليها الامر الذي قد يجعله قادرا على
محاكاه الذكاء البشري الاتمته
هو الاعتماد على الماشين حتى تساعد بتسريع
خطوط العمل واتخاذ بعض القرارات اللي كان
يتطلب وجود بني ادم حتى يتخذها القرارات
مما يساعد على رفع انتاجيه او تخفيض الكلف
بالشركات نماذج عديده عكست ما تحمله
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه من تقدم للالات
الذكيه لتعزيز مكانتها
بعد ان احتلت وظائف كانت دوما حكرا على
البشر فصارت تلعب الموسيقى وترسم اللوحات
تنظف المنازل وتؤمنها تقدمت في الوظائف
الخطيره حلت محل الانسان في المطارات
والمستشفيات والمطاعم والمقاهي وحتى في
الملاعب ورغم كل ذلك لم تشبع الاله تقدمت
النشرات وتحدثت في المؤتمرات وردت على
الاستفسارات
في المملكه المتحده الف سكان مدينه ميلتون
كينز شمال العاصمه البريطانيه لندن مشهد
روبوتات التوصيل الذكيه تجوب شوارع
المدينه حيث تدير شركه ستارشيب نحو 200
روبوت اليك يقومون بتوصيل الاطعمه الساخنه
والطرود ومواد البقاله الى سكان المدينه
الصغيره الروبوتات مزوده باجهزه استشعار
مع 12 كاميرا مع بطاريات تمكنها من السير
بسرعه اربعه اميال في الساعه ما يعادل
سرعه المشي السريع لدى البشر
في الشهر الاول لتفعيل خدمه التوصيل عبر
الروبوتات في مقاطعه كامبورغ في مدينه
كامبرج والتي حلت بها الروبوتات في العام
2022 ساهم ذلك في توفير ما يقدر بسبعه
الاف وسبعمائه
السيارات وتقليل انبعاثات ثاني اكسيد
الكربون بمقدار واحد فاصله 670 كيلو جرام
من ناحيه سيفتي كانت اكثر وخاصه للناس
اللي عندهم مشاكل صحيه والكبار في العمر
او السكنيه لوحده من البيت كانت اسرع طبعا
لانه الطلب بيجي
لبيت واحد يستطيع الانسان القيام باعمال
التوصيل بشكل اسرع نحن بامكاننا القياده
بسرعه عاليه بينما تعجز الروبوتات عن ذلك
انه لامر محزن نشعر كبشر ان قمتنا في مجال
اعمالنا اخذه في التناقص خاصه عندما
تنافسنا روبوتات بامكانيات ف انا ما بعمل
مضره لانسان وبستخدم التكنولوجيا في نفس
الوقت اذا لم تكن تلك الروبوتات موجوده
فبالتاكيد كان البشر هم من سيقومون بتلك
الاعمال ما يعني تامين مصادر دخل لهم لا
تستطيع الروبوتات العمل من تلقاء نفسها هي
تدار عبر البشر مع تطور الحياه اصبح الناس
يبحثون عن حلول اكثر حداثه وروبوتات
التوصيل مثال لذلك لذا فانا لا استغرب ان
تاخذ تلك الروبوتات وظائفنا في المستقبل
القريب
ستؤدي عمليه ادمته الوظائف الى ازاحه
الاشخاص عن اعمالهم وهنا تصبح الامور اكثر
ريبه لان السؤال هنا سيكون حسنا ماذا
سيعمل هؤلاء الاشخاص بدلا من ذلك كان
المامول في البدايه ان يساهم الذكاء
الاصطناعي في دعم انتاجيه البشر لكننا
بدنا نرى كيف صارت وظائف البشر انفسهم
عرضه للاستبدال لذا اعتقد اننا في سباق
بين مزايا ومساوئ الذكاء الاصطناعي
ربما لم يتوقع احد ان تزاحم الاله الذكيه
وظائف البشر الابداعيه فقد فاجات
الجارديان البريطانيه جمهورها في سبتمبر
من العام 2020 بمقال افتتاحي كتبه برنامج
للذكاء الاصطناعي بينما طور مبرمجون
اكوادا تمكن الاله من نظم الشعر مستفيده
في ذلك من قاعده ضخمه للبيانات تضم الاف
القصائد لفحول الشعر العربي فتنسج على
منوالها لك الريح وما تحت السماء من
البلاد فداك كان لبعض الناس فيما قدها
كافر
جدل كبير اثارته لوحه فنيه حملت اسم مسرح
اوبرا الفضاء عندما احتلت الصداره في
مسابقه لمتحف ولايه كولورادو الامريكيه اذ
لم يستطع المحكمون تمييز ما ان كانت
اللوحه من صنع مبدع بشري ام اله ذكيه هناك
بشكل مباشر على الرصيد الهائل من تصاميم
سابقه للفنانين مبدعين انا متخوف من ان
تتعرض اعمالي للسرقه واستخدامها بدون اذن
مني ويعد هذا انتهاك لحقوق الملكيه
الفكريه الخاصه به التصميم هو ما بيتعلق
بس بانه خلق جرافيكس جديده وبس التصميم هو
عمليه بتحتاج لشيء انساني اكتر بكتير فيها
دراسه للسوق في التصوير البراند للشيء
المطلوب من المصمم لم يطلب مني كمصمم اي
عمل باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي واتمنى ان
لا ياتي احد ويطلب مني هذا النوع من
الاعمال وهذا يعتبر كابوس لكل مصمم قد
تعلم مجتهد وتدرب وراك من الخبرات في
دائما هذه اللمس الانسانيه اللمس
الانسانيه ما وصلنا لمرحله نحولها لكود
ونقدر نبني عليه ماذا قال الصناعي ياخذ هي
القرارات هي المرحله نزلت كتير صعب انه
يكون منافس حقيقي
للمصمم الاداري
تشهد تطبيقات الترجمه المعتمده على الذكاء
الاصطناعي تطورا كبيرا اذ يتوقع ان يتجاوز
سوق الترجمه الاليه سبعه فاصل خمسه مليار
دولار امريكي بحلول عام 2030 ما يطرح
التساؤل عن كفاءه تلك الترجمه وقدرتها على
احتلال وظائف المترجمين التقليديين
من لحظه انه يصلي انا طلب الترجمه للحظه
ان نسلم الترجمه في كتير امور اداريه
الذكاء الاصطناعي انا كثير بساعدني فيها
ليش انا بدي ضايع وقتي على هذا الاشياء
اذا فيي انا استخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي استخدامه بترجمه ساعدنا
كثير
بخدمه عملائنا اول شيء ارتفعت الجوده عدد
الكلمات اللي بنقدر نقدمها للعميل تضاعفت
الكوست نزل على العميل اذا المترجم ضعيف
الترجمه الاليه ما بتساعده بالعكس بتضره
الاله مش زي الانسان من ناحيه حتى لو
تطورت بتضلها بتترجم كلمه بكلمه اكثر من
انها الترجمه المعاني والسياقات بشكل عام
خلال السنوات يلي مديت مع تطور هالانظمه
لترجمه تلقائيه ولا ذكاء الاصطناعي ما بقى
بحاجه لعدد كبير من المترجمين لحتى يعملوا
نفس الشغل يلي ممكن انه المشين ترانزيشن
تعملها ويشرف عليها اثنين او ثلاثه بدل ما
عشرين شخص مثلا يشتغلوا عليها في بعض
الاحيان يكونوا من الافضل الاحتفاظ بالقوه
العامله البشريه بدلا من الانتقال الى
الاتمته لحمايه مصادر دخل الناس
انه لا يمكن الاستهانه بقدرات الذكاء
الاصطناعي فتاثيره المستقبلي كبير فقد
اصبح يتماسك مع جميع الوظائف تقريبا
بطريقه
مجال اخر تقدمت فيه الاله لتنافس على مهام
ووظائف خدمه العملاء
يعرف بالدردشه الاليه وهي تطبيقات ذكيه
تحاكي محادثه البشريه وهو ما بات مالوفا
مع عشرات المواقع الالكترونيه التي
نرتادها كل يوم بلغ حجم السوق العالمي
لخدمات الدردشه الاليه ثلاثه فاصله ثمانيه
وسبعين مليار دولار امريكي في العام 2021
مع توقع بتسجيل معدل نمو سنوي مركب قدره
30.29 في الفتره ما بين 2022 و 2017
الى قنوات الاتصال بتعتمد على النص مثل
الفيسبوك ماسنجر الانستجرام واتساب الويب
سايت او المساعد الصوتي اللي نحن نستهدف
فيه مراكز الاتصال بالشركات
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت وظائف الكور سنتر او وظيفه موظف
في الكورس انت المهدده او لا بوجود الذكاء
الاصطناعي فانا بتوقع انه لا ما راح تكون
مهدده لكن رح تقلل عدد الموظفين يتم
استبدال وظيفه اليوم ممكن لكن لا اعتقد ان
هذا الشرح يصير ضمن حياتي انا صراع جديد
ما بين تحديات وفرص يقدمها الذكاء
الاصطناعي للبشريه مما سمح بمزيد من القلق
على مستقبل يغلب فيه ذكاء الاله ذكاء
الانسان
في ان الذكاء الاصطناعي غالبا ما يتم
تصويره وخاصه في وسائل الاعلام الاكثر
اثاره على انه قادر على تجسيد قدرات البشر
هذه طريقه مضلله للغايه في النظر الى تلك
التقنيات فالكثير من الاشياء التي يتم
تصنيفها على انها ذكاء اصطناعي ليس الذكيه
الى حد كبير فهي لا تعدو كونها مجرد
خوارزميات تعمل لانتاج مخرجات معينه بوتس
هذا الذك اصطناعي يتعلم منا قد ما نحن
بدنا نعلمه هو منه ذكاء نحن بنعمله ذكي
وبنسميه ذكي بس هو منه ذكي اعتقد ان هناك
مجالات عديده يكون فيها العامل البشري
افضل من الالات فالذكاء العاطفي وتفسير
الاشارات الدقيقه للسلوك البشري وفهم
الامور النفسيه وما الى ذلك جميعها يصعب
جدا على تلك الالات فهمها وجود العنصر
البشري كتير المهم لو بدنا نروح على سوبر
ماركت ونحن عم نعمل الاسكان عند المشتريات
احيانا بوقف الجهاز فبتضطر انك انت تطلبي
اسيستنت من الموظف الموجود بالسوبر ماركت
فدائما العنصر البشري لازم هو اللي يدقق
اذا غيب البشر عن تاديه الاعمال فستكون
الوظائف مجرد مهام اليه بلا روح الانسان
بحب يستانس يعني بحب يكون شايف قدامه شخص
بشري عم يحكي معه مش دائما مكانات
بسبب كتير بسيط انه الانسان هو اللي عم
نعمل
بيانات ومدخلات لا حصر لها تستقبلها
الالات الذكيه عن سلوك البشر وعاداتهم
وتفضيلاتهم مما قد يستدعي دورا رقابيا
يحفظ للانسان خصوصيته استخدام بعض
التطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يفقدنا
الاستقلاليه والخصوصيه ويعرض قيمنا
وثقافتنا للتهديد وحتى ادراكنا لقيمه ان
نكون بشرا صار عرضه للتهديد تحولات عالميه
كبرى يقودها الذكاء الاصطناعي منذ عقدين
من الزمن مدت الدول العربيه اكثر تبانا في
التعاطي معها فبينما حريصه الدول الاغنى
على تبني تلك التقنيات مفصحه المجال لها
في خططها الاستراتيجيه لم تعرها دول اخرى
نفس الاهتمام اذ اظهر المؤشر العالمي
للذكاء الاصطناعي من تورتس انتلجنس
وقائمته التي تضم اثنتين وستين دوله هذا
التباين بوضوح
التاثير الايجابي الوحيد لكوفيد 19 انه
لفت انتباه للشركات والمنظمات والحكومات
على ضروره التسريع بتبني هاي التكنولوجيا
حتى نقدر احنا نمشي وننمو كمجتمعات
كاقتصادات عربيه لا ينبغي ان تكون الدول
والشعوب والضحايا للذكاء الاصطناعي فان
كان من الصعب اعاده الامور الى الوراء فان
الحكومات بامكانها ان تلعب دورا في رسم
مساحات العمل الخاصه بها ووضع اللوائح
المنظمه لذلك اتوقع انه في مسؤوليه على
المجتمعات وعلى الحكومات وعلى الشركات
لاعاده تاهيل الناس اللي كانت تشتغل
بوظائف تم استبدالها من خلال ذكاء الصناعي
حتى نقدر احنا نسخرهم لوظائف مختلفه ويكون
في لهم دور في الثوره الجديده لازم كل
الجامعات
يعلموا على كيف فيهم يستخدموا هالادوات
لانه هذا التطور اتى ليبقى ونحن اذا بدنا
نحن كمان على السوق لازم نحن نعرف نستخدمه
انا اؤمن بشده بان الانسان في يومنا هذا
اصبح لديهم قدره على ان يطور نفسه وياخذ
مهارات جديده يكتسبها ويتعلمها بحيث يواكب
هذا التطور في التقنيه يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار قدره البشر على القيام بمهامه لا
حصر لها لما يمتلكون من مهارات واسعه
وقدرات امل ان يكون هناك حراك عالمي يضع
قواعد منظمه لاستخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي
يدعم النظم والثقافات والقيم المحليه
لا اعتقد انه من الممكن عرقله انتشار
الذكاء الاصطناعي الاقدام على ذلك سيكون
له عواقب وخيمه على الاقتصاد وسيخلق مشاكل
اجتماعيه ومهنيه السؤال الحقيقي الان هو
كيف يمكننا حمايه البشر من تغول الذكاء
الاصطناعي كيف نتحكم فيه ونطوعه بما يحقق
النتائج المفيده في
اذا تتباين الاراء حول الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهذا موضوع حلقتنا نرحب بكم مشاهدينا
الكرام ونرحب ايضا بضيفين الكريمين هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور احمد خليفه المقرمد وهو
المدير التنفيذي المؤسس لمعهد قطر لبحوث
الحوسبه ومن تورنتو يسعدنا ان نستقبل
ونرحب بالدكتور دانيال الارايه خبير
الذكاء الاصطناعي والحوكمه وشريك رئيس في
القمه القانونيه العالميه زميل الاول في
مركز الابتكار في الحوكمه الدوليه لبحوث
الذكاء الاصطناعي والانظمه المستقله اهلا
بضيفين الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك دكتور
احمد هنا في الاستوديو كما ذكرنا تباينه
الاراء حتى في هذا الفيلم الذي عرضناه بين
من يبشر بثوره من صنع البشر لصالح البشر
وبين من يرى بان هذا الذكاء سيتوغل على
الذكاء البشري كيف تراه انت
طبعا انا متفائل جدا في هذا الموضوع لان
الذكاء الاصطناعي
التحول الرقمي بصفه عامه اثبت انه هو شيء
مهم جدا ومؤثر جدا في حياه البشر احنا
الان نعيش احسن تقريبا من احسن اوقات
الانسانيه
مستوى المعيشه ارقى من اي وقت الناس اللي
في السوق العمل
درجه التعليم اعلى من اي وقت في المؤشرات
كلها يعني عاليه مبشره فلا اعتقد انا
الصوره بهذا
القتامه ايوه
اذا كان اصطناعي كاي تكنولوجي تانيه كاي
كما وريت انت في العرض الاول كاي
تكنولوجيا تانيه لها اول ما تطلع
التكنولوجيا يكون فيها تخوف الناس طبعا
تخيف من اي شيء جديد
مثلا شوفي الانترنت لما دخلت علينا
الانترنت
في الاول كان في تخوف ولكن ساوت ما بين
الناس في مثلا اصبح اي واحد ممكن ينتج
محتوى ايوه اي واحد ممكن يستفيد من
معلومات الموجوده اي واحد ممكن يحضر
كورسات في ارقى جامعات في العالم هو موجود
في الدوحه او موجود في قريه صغيره في
افريقيا وفي اي مكان اصبح التوصل الى
معلومات
طبيه او توصل الى دكتور عن بعد متاح من
الانترنت لكن هناك ايضا حتما سلبيات كما
كل تكنولوجيا او تقنيات توضع في السوق
يرتكرها الانسان يبقى الضمير الانسان يبقى
تقنين هذه التقنيات ربما هو المنحك يعني
يتحول الدكتور ارايا ونود ان نسمع وجهه
نظر الدكتور ارايا يعني اود ان ابدا معك
من اين انتهت قصتنا عن حمايه الانسان من
تغول هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي لا يمكن الى
اين يمكن ان يقودنا باعتقادك الى اين
وصلنا اليوم فيما يخص هذا الذكاء
الاصطناعي
ابدا نتفق مع زميلي يجب ان نكون متفائلنا
بشان المستقبل
ولكن في ذات الوقت ثمت خطوره مرتبطه
بالاتمته وايضا
الامور المتصله بالذكاء الاصطناعي لان هذا
سوف يؤثر على منظوماتنا الاجتماعيه طبعا
هذه قضيه مرتبطه بالحكومات لكي تضع حلا
لها ولكن على مستوى اخر يجب ان ننظم
الذكاء الاصطناعي على مستوى عالمي ربما
واستخدام البيانات ايضا لان البيانات هي
التي تغذي الذكاء الاصطناعي
وطبعا الذكاء الاصطناعي هو يتعلمه من
البيانات ولذلك يجب ان نقوم بتدابير كثيره
واعتقد ان هناك شوط طويل يجب ان نقطعه هو
ما يوضع في الذكاء الاصطناعي هو نقطه مهمه
جدا وقد تمت الاشاره اليها حتى من قبل
دكتور ارايا لكن رغم تفاؤلكما كلاهما
وكلاكما يعني في المجال العلمي يعني نحن
عامه البشر في المشاهدين الكرام الذين
يتابعوننا الليله لديهم هذا التخوف وهذا
اله اجس الذي في الواقع تصدقه ايضا تقارير
دوليه مثلا تقرير للبنك اشار الى ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يحل محل ما
يعادل 300 وظيفه حول العالم ولعل ربما هذا
التخوف الاكبر يعني حتى من الوظائف
الابداعيه نتحدث عن كتابه مقالات نضل
الشعر ايضا رسم لوحات يعني وبالتالي ربما
هنا التخوف
هنا في معهد قطر اللي بحوت الحوسبه اخذنا
دراسه دقيقه
المجال العمل
مثلا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي حيستحوذ على عمل
المذيعه او العمل
يعني امورها طيبه وتقدم نشاط اخبار ايضا
ان احنا ناخذه
هي صفه العمل صفه الوظيفه ونشوفوا الى
التاسكس اللي هي مثلا اي صفر عندك
الاسم الوظيفي بس عندك الاشياء اللي هي
المهام اللي هي في هذه الوظيفه حين تكون
عشرين ثلاثين مهمه حللنا هذه المهام
وشفنا ايش هي
المهام اللي هي ممكن يقيم بها
الاله وبعدين في نفس الوقت اخذنا في طبعا
في بنك معلومات دولي اسمه اونيت اللي هو
فيه مئات الالاف ملايين
[موسيقى]
الوظائف حل انها كلها حطيناها في الاله
حللناها وبعدين اخذنا اكثر من مليون
براءه اقتراح
ونفس الشيء حطيناها في نفس
اللوغاريتمات في نفس البرنامج ما الذي
توصلتم اليه وتوصلنا اليه انه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن يستحوذ على بعض
الوظائف هذا البعض كم نسبته تقريبا
الذكاء الاصطناعي حيتمم العمل ما
في تكامل مثلا زي ما ذكرت
السيده في
المقدمه في الفيلم ان يعني في حاجات اللي
هي ممكن
المذيع مش لازم يعملها تحضير
الابحاء البحث وكذا وغيرها ففي جزء مثلا
اكثر جزء من الاعمال اللي هي ممكن ياخذها
الذكاء الاصطناعي هي الاعمال المكتبيه
الاعمال الروتينيه اللي هي فيها نعتمد على
يعني
الكول سنتر مثلا حاجات هادي فالاشياء هذه
احنا طبعا في في عندنا عمل تقرير اللي هو
التاثير الذكاء الاصطناعي لسوق العمل وحتى
حللنا المعلومات في قطر الدراسه اللي
عملناها بمن هي ضمت برضو براءه الاختراع
احنا حاولنا نعرفه ايش هي الحاجات اللي هي
ممكن يصير لها ميكنه مثلا ما اكثر
المجالات التي يمكن فعلا الاستفاده فيها
الموضوع دون الغاء وظائف البشر يعني اغلب
الوظائف لا يستغنى عليها ولكن بعض الوظائف
الروتينيه مثلا زي
الكول سنتر مثلا
في بعض الحاجات اللي هي
فيها تكرير
ممكن ولكن بصفه
جيوشا من البطالين ماذا عن البشر الذين
يعملون في هذه المهن التي تصفها بانها
ربما اوتوماتيكيه لكن لحد الان هناك بشر
من يقوم بالعكس
يعني ان شاء الله يعني نؤمن ان
فيه تطوير مثلا لما صارت ذكرت الثوره
الصناعيه الدوره الزراعيه ما صارت في
ميكنه واصبح الاعتماد على على البشر
مباشره يقل لان في ماكينات الان اللي هي
تزرع وتحصد وكذا تساعد وتكمل مثل ما ذكرت
دكتور احمد عمل البشره تسهل ايضا بصفه
عامه في سوق العمل
الانسان يرتقي الى وظيفه
تحتاج الى تميز اكثر وتحتاج الى تفكير
اكثر يحتاج الى معلومه اكثر
بس عشان نخصص على قطر احنا في في قطر
القوه العامله في قطر
متعلمه مقارنه بباقي الدول
سهل انك
تمرنهم على عمل جديد وانك انت ترفع
مستواهم لان هم اغلب الناس اللي يشتغلوا
تلاقي انهم هم
يشتغلوا في عمل اقل من مستواهم التعليمي
احنا عنا مثلا تقريبا 50 الف
قطري عند 700 الف
مقيم
ممكن ببساطه تدريبهم
وتحسين العمل الذي يقوموا به انا مش نعطيك
فكره ان كل شيء
وردي وكل شيء وهذه النقطه التي اود ان
انتقل بها للدكتور قرايه يعني انا هنا حتى
يعني اطرح الاسئله بتاع المشاهد كما يصور
لنا الدكتور احمد ان هناك الكثير من
الايجابيات لكن مثل كل تقنيه عندما تظهر
يعني هو تحدث عن قطر كنموذج قطر يعتبر بلد
متطور لديه الامكانيات لكن هناك بلدان
يعني في افريقيا كيف يمكن ان تستفيد حتى
بالنسبه للانترنت هناك قرى نائيه صحيح انه
رويدا رويدا بدا يصل الانترنت لكن ماذا عن
هذه التقنيات كيف يمكن ان يتم الاستفاده
فيها في هذه الدول الناميه الدول الفقيره
الدول التي ليست لديها بنيه تحتيه حتى
لتسويق هذا النوع من الذكاء باعتقادك
نعم هذا سؤال كبير
وطبعا يقع
وافقوا مع بعض التحولات المرتبطه
بالعالم الواحد وايضا العالم متعدده الى
الاقطاب والصين تم تبليهم من بنيه تحتيه
وتدعيه ذلك على نشر التكنولوجيا وبالتالي
هذا السؤال ليس سؤالا بسيطا لنا يتعلق
الامر به العالم الاول او الثاني المنظومه
معقده ووفقا لهذه المنظومه الذكاء
الاصطناعي ينزع الى تعزيز القدرات الخلاقه
حتى في العالم الاول فسيكون هنالك اختلاف
عندما يتعلق الامر بالاقتصاد الناشئه فان
هنالك اختلالات سوف تدفع من قبل بعض الناس
الذين يستخدمون هذه الالات على نحو الناجع
وهذه الالات سوف يعلو كعبها
[موسيقى]
وما يحدثه من الثوره ايضا لكن اود ان ابقى
معك دكتور ارايا فيما يخص ربما تحذيرات
التي او التخوفات على الاقل ليس فقط من
عامه البشر قادت
القطاع التكنولوجي
ايضا اطلقوا رساله مفتوحه حذروا فيها من
المخاطر مما سموه المخاطر الجسيمه على
المجتمع والانسانيه من انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي والسؤال حقيقه ما الذي يمكن ان
يخشاه هؤلاء يعني قاده كبرى شركات
التكنولوجيا وما الذي يريدونه بالضبط
باعتقادك
[موسيقى]
هنالك خيارات محدوده فيما يخص ابطاء هذه
العمليه ولكن
التشريعات مهمه للغايه هم الاهميه بمكان
للبداني ان تبدا بالنقاش بشان
هذه
القطاعات الجديده وكيف يمكن وضع قيود
عليها ممتازه هذه نقطه مهمه بدات بها في
الواقع دكتور احمد هو التقنين والتشريعات
لكن قبل ذلك اود ان افتح قوسنا في نقطه
مهمه اشار اليها دكتور
يعني هذا التطبيق الذي ربما احدث ضجه انت
رايت بان للذكاء الاصطناعي عده عوامل
ايجابيه منها ربما تحسين القدرات للموظفين
اجمالا الموجودين واعطيت مثلا هنا في دوله
قطر لكن هناك من يحذر من مثل هذه البرامج
بانها يعني تساعد البعض على الغش انصح
التعبير يعني هناك ربما اعتراف نشير اليه
الان لطلاب جامعيين في بريطانيا لانهم
كتبوا مقالات مساعده برنامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي
وحصلوا على تقييمات عاليه جدا نتيجه لذلك
ما الذي يفعل كل ذلك بسهر الليالي
بالتحصيل العلمي الذي ربما يقوم به كثيرون
كما عهدناه في اجيال سابقه حتى يتمكنوا من
التحصيل العلمي وفق اصوله نعم
بعقب على
الدكتور
ان مثلا السيوم تاع جوجل
لشركه جوجل حذر
في الايام اللي فاتت بس هو حذر انه جوجل
ما تستطيعش الواحد تحل هذه المشكله يعني
هو نفسه يشير الا احنا في حاجه الى
حتى الى
[موسيقى]
محتاجين تشريعات محتاجين قوانين محتاجين
حوكمه محتاجين ندرسه عمليه الاخلاقيات في
التطبيقات هذه فهو ما قالش ان احنا نوقفه
لانه هو عنده بارد ويشتغل على بارد
رغم انه هو يستخدم هذه التقنيه في شركاته
وغيرها قصه اخرى قصه اخرى
هو مسؤول على تسلا وتستخدم
وليست يعني لم تصل لدرجه النجاح اللي هو
ارجاعها فانا ما اعرف هذا ممكن عنده هو
يعني اسباب ثانيه كيف تقدر تعمل تبطيء في
التقدم انا اعتقد التكنولوجيا والمعرفه زي
الزجاجه
فيها الجنيه لفتحت الزجاج طلعت الجنيه ما
تقدر ترجعها في الزجاجه زي ما صارلنا في
السوشيال ميديا كانت في فوضى في
استخداماتها في تطبيقاتها استغلت بطرق مش
جيده
لا تزال نعم
احنا بس نحاول قدر الامكان انه ما نوصلش
لمرحله فوضى زي ما صار عندنا الان في
الفيك نيوز لو الموضوع ترك مفتوح
في درجه اثبت من الان تخيل انه في الان
فيك فيديو
يعني عندك ممكن تنتج فيديو اللي احنا
الاثنين نتكلموا عنا المقابله هذه ونقول
كلام يختلف تماما في يعني زي ما تفضلتي
محتاجين حوكمه محتاجين قوانين محتاجين
تشريعات ولكن السؤال لان دائما اسال فيه
وسالته كم مره
كيف احنا نقدر نشرعه لشيء احنا مش فاهمينه
الان التكنولوجيا قاعده في صدده التطوير
في الواقع يعني شئنا او لم نشا
ان دائما التقنين
تتبع التكنولوجيا
يعني
ما تتقدمش التكنولوجيا
دائما التكنولوجيا ليدس
في كل الاشياء حتى لو مثلا في الجرائم
جرائم الالكترونيه كيف تطلع قوانين عندما
تحدث الجريمه تطلع القوانين للاسف هذا هو
الاربمان
هذه عملت ثوره عملت زوبعه
كبير يعني حتى بالنسبه لنا احنا نشتغل في
هذا المجال يعني احنا الان مثلا البحوث
والحوسبه عنا ثلاثه اقسام وواحد من
الاقسام يشتغل في تقنيه اللغه العربيه
هدول يشتغلوا في الترجمه يشتغلوا اللي هو
تحويل المنطوق الى مكتوب ناطق عنا نظم
كثيره
يعني
اللي هو العلم اللي عليه
خلانا يعني نتوقف ونعيد النظر لشغلنا كله
كيف احنا نقدر يعني فهذا نعتبر احنا الان
في الفتره هديه وانا اعتقد يعني في السته
شهور عندنا نهايه السنه
الرماد والتراب
حينزل شوي وحبدا عنا رؤيه اوضح
كيف
طريقه استخدام هذه التكنولوجيا التي تعتبر
يعني تطبيقات هديه طلعت جديده
وكيف نقدر نستفيدوا منها بطريقه احسن
بس الان الحديث كله على
ولكن الاستخدامات يعني لا لا ما نتصور انا
مثلا نحي من الطب نعم مثلا في استخدامات
ممكن تكون خاطئه ممكن يصير اخطاء ولكن
الفوائد كثيره ممتاز احنا هذه هي النقطه
التي اود ان اتحدث بها مع الدكتور رايه
الاستخدامات كثيره الفوائد اكثر رغم وجود
السلبيات كيف يمكن بالفعل ان نستفيد من
هذه الايجابيات هل الوقت الان فعلا لربما
الغوص اكثر في موضوع تشريعات سن القوانين
وضع ضوابط لهذا الموضوع حتى لا يفرط الجني
من القمقم كما ذكر الدكتور احمد باعتقادك
دكتور قرايه
نعم اعتقد
انت محقه
التكنولوجيا هي التي تسبق التشريعات تقترف
اخطاء في بعض الاحيان انشطه اجراميه ترغم
المشرعين على الاستجابه وهذا امر حتمي
مسار حتمي ولكن ثمه تداعيات على مؤسساتنا
على سبيل المثال الكثير من المؤسساتنا في
الغرب
قائمه على الفهم الصناعي
للاقتصادي وكيف يعمل وكيف تعمل مجتمعاتنا
وبالتالي الكثير من هذه المؤسسات تتلكا
ولا تلحقوا بالركب وهذا واضح في جلسات
الكونغرس في الولايات المتحده الامريك الى
مؤسسه تستجيب وبسرعه ونحتاج الى خبراء في
هذا الحيز هو جزء من المشكله مرتبطه
بالنظام التعليمي النظام التعليمي يعود
الى فتره سابقه
الاصطناعيه يقوم بكتابه مقالات تقنع
الاساتذه بانها كاتبها مميز ويمكن ان تطلب
او يطلب الطالب من هذه التكنولوجيا ان
تقوم بكتابه مقالته وهذا ما يحدث
اختلالاته في النظام التعليمي انا قمت
بدراسه الدكتوره منذ عشر سنوات وتلك
الفتره تبدو وكانها بعيده جدا عقود بعيد
عن تشاد جي بي تي اليوم وبالتالي فان
والمنصات المختلفه
والانترنت واستخداماتها وتطبيقات الاضافيه
سوف تحول هذه الصراعه وكيف تتنافس فيما
بينها وكيف ستبنى المؤسسات في قادم
وبالتالي صعوبه بمكان ان نقذف بالغيب
ولكن يجب ان نتوكل الحضاره لان السلبيات
سوف تكون بالفعل ملحوظه تماما
الان اليونسكو ايضا تدعو الى حوار عالمي
حول اخلاقيات الذكاء الاصطناعي السؤال
حقيقه ما امكانيه حدوث ذلك في ظل هذا
السباق الان بين القوى الكبرى ايضا في هذا
المجال
فنعم صعيب جدا
لان اخلاقيات مجتمع ما ستكون مختلفه عن
اخلاقيات المجتمع اخر الامور نسبيه طبعا
اخلاقياته مهمه جدا ولكن الامر الاهم
مرتبط بمن يملك البيانات وكيف تهضمها او
يهضمها الذكاء الاصطناعي وكيف يمكن حمايه
البشر يمكن ان نتصالح مع وجود البيانات
وكما تعرفون هنالك
مساحات في الصين وفي اوروبا تعنى بهذه
المسائل الامريكيه بطيئه في هذا التفصيل
عندما يتعلق الامر بهذه التنفسيه لا يمكن
ابطاء الذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن يجب سن
القوانين ويجب ان يكون هناك حمايه خلاقه
وسيما فيما يخص البيانات الخاصه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي التوالدي وبالتالي يجب ان نركز
على البيانات اكثر من اي وقت س وهنالك
تقدم احرزه في هذا المقام ولكن ثمه مشكله
التكنولوجيات ذات الغرض الكبير ترتبط
بذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يرتبط ايضا
بالمؤسسات العسكريه وبالتالي اذا ما كان
هنالك مساحه لتعزيز هذه الادوات فان هناك
تنافس سوف يطفو على السطح وبالتالي هنالك
مجاهيل يجب ان ننخر عباده ايضا مصحه
التعبير ويجب ان
ننظر في هذه الامور قبل ان نصل الى ازمه
المستفحله دكتور احمد مره اخرى الى منطقه
العربيه مشاهدنا يعني طبعا متواجد في
المنطقه العربيه ويهمه ان يعرف عنا ايضا
اكثر يعني اين نحن من هذا السباق في هذه
التكنولوجيا اين موقعنا عرب في هذه
الخريطه انتاجا واستهلاكا
بنعلق على نقطه المخاطر دراسه المخاطر شيء
مهم واحنا يعني في
بتعاون معها وزاره الاتصالات
والمعنيين هنا في الدوله دائما نتحدث على
الحمايه من المخاطر
فالموضوع يكون دائما
عملي وعلمي احنا عندنا تكنولوجيا مثلا
الامن السيبراني الان في اختراقات هل يعني
ذلك نحن نوقف التعامل
مثلا التمويل او مع البنوك الالكترونيه لا
طبعا فيه يعني
في تعامل احنا دائما ندرس مخاطر الان احنا
عندنا نقاش جاد في دراسه المخاطر
اللي هي تنتج عن استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
حتى احنا ندخل في العمليه هذه بعيون
مفتوحه
فاحنا مثلا عنا في قطر من اوائل الدول
التي اسست
استراتيجيه وطنيه للذكاء الاصطناعي واعلنت
في 2019 من قبل رئاسه الوزاره
الاستراتيجيه هذه وضعت من معهد الحوسبه
ووزاره الاتصال الدكتور احمد اذا مثل ما
ذكرته لكن اذا حاولنا ان نوسع قليلا هناك
تباين حتما في الدول العربيه المنطقه
العربيه ليست ظروفها كلها متشابهه اين نحن
بالمجمل كعرب من هذا السباق
طبعا اكيد ان
نحل الموضوع هذا كمستهلكين وكمنتجين فكم
مستهلكين
ما عنا اي ان خيار لان احنا حنستورد اجهزه
طبيه هنستورد اجهزه
[موسيقى]
حنستورد
نظم معلومات
نستخدمها كل المجال كمنتجين هذه
كمستهلكين الذكاء الاصطناعي موجود في
فاحنا لازم نعرف تاثيرها وكيف نتعامل
معاها وكيف ندرس المخاطر وكيف عن طريق
تشريعات زي ما ذكرنا في الاول من ناحيه
الانتاج فيه يعني جهد كبير مثلا على سبيل
المثال زي ما ذكر السيد ابراهيم ان
التعليم
في قطر وفي المنطقه في
مثل احنا في جامعه حمد بن خليفه نعطي عده
شهادات في تحليل البيانات في الذكاء
الاصطناعي وبعدين لازم احنا نعتني
التعليم المستمر اللي بعد الشهاده في مجال
العمل ما فيش مثلا اصبح الان مستحيل ان
واحد يتخرج ويشتغل لازم دائما يعني في
دراسه اي بالضبط وهذه طبعا احنا فيها يعني
مرحله جيده
في الخليج في عده دول يعني في في تقدم
الجزء الثالث اللي هو معاهد بحثيه في
معاهد بحثيه جيده في العالم العربي وانا
طبعا يعني
في قطر مثلا احنا نشتغل فيه الامن
السيبراني واستخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
الامن السيبراني
في المده 13 سنه اللي فاتت في تقنيات
اللغه في
الاتصالات في المواصلات في كذا
بعطيك على سبيل المثال بس عشان نكون محدد
عندنا تقريبا اكثر من 260 براءه اختراع
او اللي هي اصدرت والا تحت المراجعه في
امريكا عنا تقريبا ثمانيه شركات جديده بما
فيها
كناري اللي هي
ترجمه ونقل محتوى واستخدمت في الجزيره من
سنوات كثيره في
نقل المنطوق الى الى مكتوب
عندنا مثلا فعندنا في عده تخصصات ايجابيه
فاحنا منتجين ولكن نحن طبعا مازلنا في دور
البدايه
واهم شيء لو تسمحي لي اهم شيء وذكر
جدا في الاستراتيجيه اللي هو البنيه
التحتيه
بنيه المعلومات والبنيه التحتيه فاحنا
شايفين الان في المنطقه في اهتمام كبير
ببنيه تحتيه مثلا في قطر في
مراكز معلومات
اللي هي مهمه جدا ما تقدر تبني ما تقدرش
تبني
انتم ذكاء اصطناعي او نظر نظم معلومات
بدون ما يكون عندكم
ما الاجدى والانفع كل دوله تبحث عن ربما
تشريعات وضع تشريعات وقوانين ضابطه لهذا
الموضوع في بلدها ام انه يجدر بناء ربما
التحرك على مستوى جماعي على مستوى عالمي
ووضع ضوابط وقوانين لنحكم هذا الموضوع
لاستفاده قصوى في نهايه الامر للانسان
واحنا ذكرنا هذا الموضوع برضو في
الاستراتيجيه مهم التعاون الدولي مستحيل
انه نشتغل لوحدنا بس احنا
نرغب في انه يصير تعاون ما بين الدول
الصغرى اللي هي فيها تماثل
متشابهه انه نشتغل مع بعض ونطلع قوانين مع
بعض وطبعا زي ما ذكر
ان الاخلاقيات
عندها علاقه بالثقافه وعندنا علاقه
بالمجتمع نفسه فيعني يعني الموضوع شويه
محتاج بس نطمنك ان احنا في الطريق السليم
وخلينا نكونوا متفائلين ان نختم فعلا معك
دكتور احمد بهذه النظره تفاؤليه التي
تشاركتها في الواقع مع الدكتور ارايا
العلم الذي اخترعه الانسان هو حتما لفائده
الانسان ان فعلا التزم الانسان
باستخداماته الايجابيه والجيده محكما
ضميره الانساني اشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور
احمد خليفه المدير التنفيذي المؤسس لمعهد
قطر لبحوث الحوسبه ضيفنا الكريم هنا في
الاستوديو كما اشكر جزيل الشكر من تورنتو
الدكتور
الاصطناعي والحوكمه شريك رئيسي في القمه
القانونيه العالميه
ختام حلقتنا هذه من برنامج القصه بقي نعود
ونلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه بقصه جديده
الاثنين القادم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]